[Musique]
les chéris aujourd'hui c'est la journée
du canon mais je le dis je vous dire
beinheim qu'un le toit c'est ainsi que
de la télé ici c'est karine karine
mecheri j'ai un petit bol avec le nombre
de chroniqueurs jeudi du chroniqueur et
oui la chute dont également donc je vous
dis c'est très simple je vais tirer deux
papiers ceux qui seront tirées ces
câlins mais qu'alain de ouf ça
d'ailleurs ça veut dire qu'alain
qu'allah nous lie à batoumi a laissé
partition du canal et on y va
[Applaudissements]
commence alors je le fais comme
inception la première folie truc ça vous
plaît alors on va voir premiers papiers
y aura pas de ces l'agent di luca l'un
des dieux qui seront tirés de vont
s'embrasser très fort gilles arcens bras
de fer avec attention avec son nom avec
avec avait dit qu'il voulait de la
galoche chili
[Rires]
c'est vrai les téléfilms c'est la
rentrée zen vous le savez qu'on reçoit
sophie davant jeu l'adorent jeu
l'aquifère mais le coma le cartel avec à
faire conclut la wii et c est le
principe c'est il amène des vieux objets
en fait des personnes amènent de vieux
objets 1 pour ensuite les grandes auprès
de personnes qui sont intéressées la
fête par ce type de projet ce type
d'objet alors je vous ai demandé à
certains d'entre vous de m'amener un
vieil objet voilà et je vais essayer de
voilà de le reprendre peut-être
jean-michel ça j'y tiens beaucoup c'est
collector c'est les quatre équipes je
mettais pour la première saison était
pmp c'est pas vrai mm d'eau dont j'avais
un par semaine passée alors juste à oui
il est quatre la justice jour là 2 bat
excusez moi voilà elle est d'origine
merci la bravo c'est méchant méchant
comme c'est le seul qui travaille pas et
partout au québec
[Applaudissements]
en acceptant un accès ce produit par
mois serait produit parfois bah oui
c'est moi qui la case sans beaucoup
nathan des nominés non mais c'est quoi
ta tendresse franck weil si t'es quoi je
change tout le pré-générique général les
chéris je vous le dis je devais faire un
truc et je vais faire complètement
d'autres pourquoi parce que il ya un
instant il s'est passé quelque chose de
très grave il ya une personne ici qui a
voulu me [ __ ] dehors de ces huit de
leurs maux je le dis aux téléspectateurs
souper donnez moi une caméra donnez moi
qui viens ici ici ici c'est pas la peine
quelle honte de leurs mots viens de dire
cyril hanouna dans un an va partir sur
m6 et c'est moi qui vais reprendre la
chaîne s'est vite en cap et au souper le
président qui passait dans les couloirs
judy attend franck reste ici de petites
secondes est vrai tu fais une rentrée
remarquable
alors moi je sais assez bien fait rire
c'était parfait mais faut pas rêver non
pour l'instant on reste assez passé le
reste du groupe n'a pas misé sur le bon
chameau le nombre d'accès si l'on écoute
tu sais pas c'est si le futur je sais
quoi pour l'instant mais vous restez sur
madère allez merci merci qu'est ce que
tu as c'est tout bon peut-être alors lui
rôles en amont porte à trépas loges et
coutach et on va te faire ouvrir la
loyère saccadé marceau s'occupe de vous
voilà c'était le président rappela dix
mois pour lui c'est pour ça qu'on aime
bon j'ai repéré quelqu'un gerra nouveaux
talents vous présenter je suis sûre tik
tok avons à leur type
ouais je regardais et je suis toute la
journée sur tik tok et j'ai repéré mamie
catherine est ce que vous l'avez vous
pas bien sûr c'est une grande marque
ajacides ouvre la respecter et non parce
que notion là notre mamie elle va
essayer de faire la même chose vous
voyez est ce qu'on peut mettre le titre
alors est-ce qu'on peut mettre le titre
connaît souviens toi non je connais pas
mais je m'étais moi le plus original le
clip original
[Musique]
jusqu'à ce que mon petit coeur
donc ça
non là mais vite est ce que tu sens on
va mettre le titre
si vous avez ce qu'ils ont fait certes
ils ont mis le au tournant
ça fait bizarre va tendre à démarrer une
mission mais nord et spa président des
jeunes ici des génies alors vas-y m
[Musique]
aussi parce que c'est parce qu'elle fait
ça va me catherine rome et paris
katherine la droite et m'a mise à la
bouche et on va mieux à lévis
[Musique]
chérissez lundi on est content m ais
benhaim j'adore sa tenue le magnifique
sans rigoler mais c'est ouf
des connaissances très content de vous
recourez et aujourd'hui c'est une
journée un peu particulière pour moi
parce que c'est l'anniversaire de celui
mine de rien je ne m'en suis jamais
caché que j'aime le plus dans l'excès
c'est mon petit protégé celui avec qui
j'ai des barrettes lui avec qui j'ai
démarré ce jury qui déterminera puis le
set
c'est l'anniversaire de noemi
[Applaudissements]
voilà
il
[Applaudissements]
bon anniversaire j'aime bien faire
plaisir qu'est ce qui te fait plaisir
après après rien il avait un truc à
retenir je vous explique le sketch la
prendre comme dans un problème m côté de
sketches je veux dire sur michel c
qu'est ce que tu veux qu'est ce que tu
veux pour verdir une augmentation je
vais attaquer quado ou quad ou tu es bon
il ya un problème
1 après je disais l'augmentation et tu
me dire par là c'est moi tu es si le
truc
bravo
[Applaudissements]